santé en manifestants c'est le moyen de
fédérer dans les cortèges et c'est
presque une tradition en France parmi
les incontournables il y a
[Musique]
l'international le chant révolutionnaire
chantait lors du défilé du premier mai
en 1973 avril 2002 Jean-Marie Le Pen
vient d'accéder au second tour de la
présidentielle dans les rues de Reims
résonne le chant des partisans l'hymne
de la Résistance
[Musique]
le chant des partisans
aujourd'hui parce que ça rappelle des
années noires de la France de
l'Allemagne qui avait envahi avec la
bataille des partisans
[Applaudissements]
pour médiatiser leur lutte certains vont
même jusqu'à parodier des chansons
[Musique]
des Compagnons de la chanson devient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un champ des militantes féministes du
lac à Aix-en-Provence et dans un autre
registre motivé du groupe toulousain
Zebda
devient
un champ contre la loi Fillon sur les
retraites en 2003 des pavés au stade il
n'y a qu'un pas et les manifestants
n'hésite pas à s'inspirer des supporters
de football quand les étudiants
marseillais manifestent contre la
réforme du bac il rend hommage
évidemment à l'Olympique de Marseille
[Applaudissements]
des slogans qui annoncent la couleur ce
matin à Marseille
c'est son entrée en lutte mais le chant
devenu incontournable depuis la
mobilisation des gilets jaunes dès 2018
c'est lui
on est là un champ emprunté à l'origine
au supporter du Racing Club de Lens
un son qui accompagne toutes les
mobilisations contre la réforme des
retraites comme ici à Clermont-Ferrand
en mars 203
[Musique]